and thanks for joining us i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis a spike in
covid cases leading ccsd to hit pause on
classes the district says schools are
overwhelmed with both infections and
staffing shortages the ccsd dashboard
shows that this month alone more than 2
000 cases have already been reported
madison kimbrough spoke to teachers and
parents tonight about that decision and
she joins us live at ccsd headquarters
madison
yeah both parents and teachers agreed
that this is needed but that wasn't the
case online as many are upset over the
sudden change
i did not see it coming so when the
email came in this afternoon i was
actually teaching
and my heart kind of stopped but i
talked to my kids about it and we all
understood why it's being done clark
county schools canceling classes this
friday and tuesday of next week in wake
of the covet 19 crisis while schools
already have martin luther king jr day
off on monday ccsd has chosen two
additional days for staff and students
to be out of the classroom staff will be
required to work from home on friday and
tuesday this was absolutely needed
myself and other teachers were seeing
our schools just being depleted of
students and staff so many students and
staff are calling out sick or unable to
get cleared to come back this
cancellation comes as ccsd has seen a
surge in the last week with over 2 200
coveted cases and because of it endured
extreme staffing shortages robert e lake
elementary school parent bruce brandon
feels like this is a necessary step it's
a process like everything else with this
whole pandemic thing but
you know what can we do but try to keep
our kids safe while others on social
media outraged at this decision the
majority of comments on our eight news
now facebook page not pleased with how
ccsd is handling things stating that
five days won't even make a difference
as for after school programs those will
be impacted too the city of las vegas is
closing the reinvent and safe keep
programs friday and tuesday classes will
resume again on wednesday january 19th
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now
madison and in a statement governor
sisilak says he understands parents may
be disappointed but he's also committed
to keeping schools open for in-person
learning